[Music]
my name and welcome to Saints Row 4 in
the evening [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is says
amigo
you know GU raishin in a beret in a in a
Gration in regulate yon in I'll go radio
integration rate basically you can
customize your your character in
singsong voice the game is not out yet
but I'm pretty [ __ ] pumped to play it
and honestly cat customizing the
characters like half the fun of the game
so I thought why why the [ __ ] not look
at that nice all right
oh I gotta create an account okay well
hey I don't look I want to make like the
sex appeal of myself which is of course
an Asian man no oh damn
oh I think this is pretty good
representation of no fine I'm sorry I
changed my mind I want to be a female oh
good they jiggle train oh my god they're
the only part that jiggle suit um I
wanna realistic as possible so I think I
would go no orange that's all is a great
color isn't it she decided that she
wasn't adding song to my share spray tan
let's make her as beautiful as possible
what I did not expect that I mean yeah
weird sex yes okay let's [ __ ] focus
here let's make her as beautiful as
possible I'm just gonna do what I look
in the girl black yeah dumb double black
is aboard what the [ __ ] why not hey
warts are high yes
[ __ ] ha ha
all right her eyes Oh frog or [ __ ] I
don't even know let's go miss frog leg
Marc beautiful
[Laughter]
girl what she's [ __ ] scary she could
be the new amnesia monster
oh it just doesn't stop does it good job
all right no that's always a good one
yes more all day yeah that makes sense
she doesn't look very happy
hi that looks like the better [ __ ]
oh yeah this is seriously how I look at
girls with Botox
it looks so [ __ ] stupid we're just
making the most fabulous girl we can you
know best duck face ever oh it's getting
better I didn't think that was possible
yeah how are you talking would you make
out with this I would you should play
this with oculus rift then just be like
ah oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
see the makeup yes oh man you look hot
girl nice she's crying because she's so
beautiful she didn't get any ice cream
dad mask of war all right personality no
whoa right there boom sad why not no I
do not and I'm very happy about it
you're you too you too
the Carlton oh damn
Thanks seriously I'm gonna go with this
one I'm gonna go with that one
let's give her an outfit before we're
done I wanted to have a good outfit ha
oh damn oh okay nice minecraft with the
[ __ ] it's pretty cool that hats already
oh nice nice I want to pick that one but
we put so much effort into her [ __ ]
face
so I don't want to cover it up you know
uh oh oh that's pretty hot okay there we
go I think we did a pretty good job I
don't know what your brother's but I'm
pretty proud of mrs. Gonzales here she's
I can't do this anymore I'm sorry should
not film this this became way more
awkward Oh Dada Dada my brain obscure
forever now I hope you're looking
forward to Saints Row 4 I'm looking
forward to playing it finally got a
upload it on youtube if you bro this one
too if you want me leave me like helps
me out a lot in either way so it's gotta
come a birthday I'll see in the next one
[ __ ] you
[Music]
yeah now what the [ __ ] don't you dare
assist my insertion what I finger you
[Music]